netflix facebook all the stuff is down
pretty significantly uh robin hood i
mean just like they're all down
is the bleeding over or is this just the
start of something that could get way
way worse yeah no i still think it's the
start of something that's going to get
worse uh way way worse you know for
netflix in particular probably not i
mean damn thing was down 30 40 percent
um but but the point is like you know
when you're in these sort of
financial market bubbles i think we can
all agree that in the past couple years
it was a bubble pull up a chart of
pretty much anything uh on a log
certainly on a non-log scale
when you're in these bubbles in the
equity market you know there's always
kind of like one or two
big companies that come out and you know
report something either earnings or
guidance that's really negative and
causes the stock to collapse you know
that's usually the beginning of the end
of the bubble i would argue facebook
last quarter was kind of like the the
predecessor for for this mover singing
netflix but you go back to the uh you
know the housing bubble uh bear stearns
kind of collapsing in 2007 was a was a
big deal uh you go back to the prior
tech bubble uh you know 2000 uh qualcomm
kind of missed and got it down and that
was kind of the end of the tech bubble
and so there's always these sort of like
seminal moments when you look back in
time and say hey look that's kind of
when like the whole valuation narrative
change and the kind of range or probable
outcomes that investors would assign to
value these companies you know really
started to shift downward and i think
that's exactly what netflix has kind of
given us the look-see on when you start
to see this uh
how do you know when the market's
bottomed like should people look for
certain uh signs to say like okay now's
the time to deploy capital which i think
is what acme was trying to do netflix
had already fallen then he went in to
buy some and he said you know we're so
glad that the market provided this
opportunity for us and then it fell
another 35 so i don't think he thought
uh he was buying something that was
falling i think he thought he was buying
something that was heavily discounted uh
and it was basically bottoming and then
he would benefit on the recovery so what
are the signs that you look for for the
stock market dakota could have bottomed
yeah so it's obviously it's impossible
to to not impossible without luck but
it's it's very difficult to ascertain
tops or bottoms in real time right and
so you have to rely on like different
sets of indicators to give you a good
sense so you know for something like on
a fundamental side of things when you're
looking for a bottom what you want to
find is is sort of one b within you know
one or two quarters of a real second
derivative inflection and growth
and generally speaking you want to be in
that part of the process where the third
derivative is already improving it's
already positive so you know that kind
of is like the the first sign that
you're getting close to the bottom from
a fundamental standpoint from a policy
standpoint you obviously want to be very
close to a dovish pivot out of the fed
or out of the major central bank of the
you know kind of economy that you're
investing in china pboc you know ecb and
so like we're obviously not anywhere
close to that we're nowhere close to a
growth bottom and then typically when
you have an event in asset markets and
this could be for single stocks could be
for credit could be for the broader
index you know typically what happens if
you're already having a problem
investors tend to over pay for
volatility near-term short data
protection and what typically marks the
bottom is sort of you rolling past the
expiration of those options they
evaporate they don't you know they don't
exist anymore investors monetize those
options and then the dealers who sort of
have to short future short things to
kind of uh hedge that that risk to the
downside they start to unwind those
trades and that tends to create that
force of bottom so neither of those
three things which i would be looking
for to ascertain a bottom and something
like netflix or the broader stock market
have occurred yet so when we start to
think about uh the reason why some of
this has happened uh stocks got super
overheated there's always on discipline
monetary fiscal policy we talked about
that uh quite uh quite a bit um there's
a very interesting comment uh that i saw
uh i think it's the allianz economic
advisor uh muhammad
alianza mohamed elairi
and uh what he described was this idea
that the federal reserve may actually
move their inflation target from two
percent
to three percent so i went down this
deep you know uh rabbit hole did this
whole uh look at that's a 50 increase
that didn't take me that much of a deep
dive to figure out right
but
what is an inflation target how does it
work right i wrote all this stuff and
the deeper i got it i was like this may
be one of the biggest stories in finance
right now that doesn't seem to be
getting a lot of attention but like do
you think that they would raise the
inflation target from two to three
percent like what would the
ramifications of that be so uh let's
let's talk about what let's go backwards
because the ramifications are more
interesting than whether or not if i
think they'll do it or not i don't think
they'll do it that's the kind of quick
takeaway uh the ramifications are very
very positive because it means the fed
has more leeway from an inflation
standpoint in terms of their reaction
function okay so if you have a higher
inflation target all things being equal
you don't need to tighten this much to
get inflation back towards neutral got
back towards the the target you know
right now core pc which is their
preferred metric is running at a
preposterously low 5.4 percent
it doesn't even sound right when you say
it out loud but let's just say it's 5.4
percent that's still you know 240 base
sorry 340 basis points above where where
they're you know so where the midpoint
of their target range is so that's a big
deal um but if it was only 240 basis
points they would have to do less
tightening less quantitative tightening
all that stuff and so whether or not
they'll do it the reason i don't think
they'll do it is because you know when
you look at most polls you know whether
it be consumer confidence readings you
know gallup polls or any sort of like
politically oriented poll
inflation really for the past few months
has really been the dominant sort of
number one fear factor in america it's
been the number one reason why people
are pissed off and so for me i think the
federal reserve just kind of gave it the
reading the tea leaves between the bite
administration jay powell and janet
yellen and all the kind of commentary
we're hearing back and forth it strikes
me that they realize that if inflation
got worse
and if they were deemed to be perceived
to be perceived to be doing
uh less than they already are to combat
inflation that would actually exacerbate
the problem make it worse for democrats
to have a successful outcome in november
although they're probably not going to
have a successful outcome in november
it's the last time we'll see a dual
democrat majority for quite quite some
time hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time